Stop asking what's the best local AI
model. And honestly, that's the wrong
question. The question that decides what
you can actually run at home is simpler
than that. How much memory does your
graphics card have? That one number
picks your model for you. So, by the end
of this video, you'll know exactly which
model to install based on what you
already own. Whether you're on an RTX
4090, an old 3060, a MacBook, or even
integrated graphics, I'll give you the
model name, the honest caveats most
coverage skips, and the exact command to
get started. One more thing up front.
Forget parameter counts for a minute. A
compressed 27 billion parameter model
can now fit into less memory than some 3
billion models from last year. That's
how fast the floor has moved. So, find
your number, look up how much VRAM your
GPU has, and follow along to your
hardware. We start at the very bottom,
the tier almost all of you already own,
4 to 8 GB. Think a used gaming card, RTX
3050, GTX 1660, RTX 2060, RTX 4060 8 GB,
AMD RX 7600,
or you're on integrated graphics with
enough shared memory, this is your
bracket. And if you're thinking, I guess
I settle for something dim, that's
outdated. The best pick here is a 3
billion parameter model from a Chinese
lab called Nanbeige. Their 4.2 release
is tiny, but it does something its size
should flatly not allow. Its trick is a
looped transformer. Instead of stacking
more layers, it runs the layers it has
more than once. So, it thinks like a
bigger model without storing a bigger
model. You get the capacity, you skip
the memory bill, and it lands. On agent
tasks, coding, and reasoning, this 3
billion model beats Qwen 3.5 at 9
billion and Gemma 4 at 12. It is
outscoring models three and four times
its size.
Look at coding specifically. On SWE
bench verified real
GitHub agent, it resolves 63%, roughly
double what the same size Quen manages.
For a model this small, that number is a
little indecent. And on GPQA Diamond, a
brutal graduate-level science exam, it
scores 87. That is a figure the flagship
models were bragging about a year ago,
now running in about 2 GB on your
laptop. So, what is it for?
Local grunt work. Tagging and sorting
your files, classifying support tickets,
labeling data, the high-volume jobs
where you want speed and privacy, not a
giant brain that costs money every call.
It is also a real assistant. Pointed at
a scaffold like Open Claw, and it will
handle multi-step office tasks and deep
research fully offline, and it beats
that 9 billion model at those, too.
It carries a 256,000
token context, so it can hold a whole
code base or a stack of documents in its
head at once. On 2 GB, no internet, no
bill, and it out reasons last year's
mid-size models. That is the new floor.
It only climbs from here.
Second-tier 8 to 24 GB, if you own RTX
3060 12 GB, RTX 3070, RTX 4060 Ti, RTX
4070, AMD 7900 GRE, or a MacBook Pro
with 16 GB unified memory, this is the
most interesting bracket right now. Now
we can get greedy, and this is where
things get a little unreal. Normally, a
27 billion model is flatly out of reach
here. In full precision, it needs about
54 GB.
Even a careful 4-bit build is 18, too
big for this card and nowhere near a
phone. A startup called Prism ML, a team
out of Caltech, fixed that. They took
Quen's 27 billion model and crushed it
down to almost nothing, and they call
the result bonsai. Here is the trick,
and it is not normal quantization. They
retrained every single weight to be one
of three values, -1, 0, or +1 ternary.
Under two bits per weight, top to
bottom, no full precision escape hatch
anywhere in the network. The payoff is
absurd. The quality build is 5.9 GB. The
tiny build is 3.9. A 27 billion
parameter model that is smaller on disk
than a full precision 2 billion model.
And that 3.9 GB version fits on an
iPhone, an actual phone. It is the first
27B class model to run on the device in
your pocket, reasoning, tool calls, even
reading images. Your gut says they must
have crushed the brains out of it. They
mostly did not. The ternary build keeps
95% of the original score. The one-bit
phone build keeps 90. Math and coding
barely move at all. And here's the part
that makes it more than a party trick.
Take the most aggressive normal 4-bit
build of this same model.
Bon Sai's one-bit version scores higher
than it while using two and one half
times less memory. It is a strictly
better trade than the quantization
everyone already trusts. It is not slow,
either. On an RTX 5090, it runs at over
160 tokens a second.
On a MacBook's M5 chip, still fast
enough to feel instant. This is a usable
daily driver, not a lab demo. And it is
free and painless to grab, Apache 2
licensed, running natively through MLX
on any modern Mac and CUDA on Nvidia
cards with a full 262,000 token context.
Download it, point a llama at it, done.
Prism ML calls this intelligence
density, and I think it is the real
story of the year. A model this smart
used to demand a real GPU. Now it lives
on your everyday card with room to
spare, and every step it runs costs you
exactly nothing.
Third tier, 24 to 96 GB. Now you have
real room. A 32 gig 5090,
a pair of cards, or a Mac with a big
pool of unified memory. So, here you
stop compressing and just run the good
model at full quality. And the good
model is the one Bonsai was carved from
in the first place. Qwen 3.6 27 billion
dents. Qwen calls it flagship level
coding in a small model, and the scores
back the brag. It posts 87.8 on GPQA
Diamond and trades blows with models
several times its size. At full
precision, it wants about 54 GB, which
finally fits here with headroom for a
long context.
But, there is a hidden tax on these
reasoning models. And if you run them
locally, you feel it in your bones. They
think out loud before answering,
sometimes for thousands of tokens. And
every one of those tokens is time you
sit there and wait. So, a small European
team called Bottlecap AI shipped a
fine-tune to fix exactly that. And the
co-founder is not a random name.
It is Tomas Mikolov, the researcher who
invented Word2Vec. They call it Thinking
Cap. Same model, same answers, but it
learned to stop overthinking. About half
the reasoning tokens on average for the
same quality output. And on some
prompts, it wraps up as much as 10 times
faster.
I want to be precise here because the
internet garbled this one. The model is
no smarter. It reaches the same score
with far less rambling, which, when you
are the one waiting on it, is the
upgrade you actually feel. So, on this
rung, the move is a pair. Run Qwen 3.6
at full quality, drop the Thinking Cap
fine-tune on top, and you get flagship
coding that answers in roughly half the
time.
Who is this bracket for? The person who
codes against a local model all day and
is tired of watching it think. Same
brains as the cloud sitting on your desk
now without the long, awkward pause
before every single answer. Fourth tier,
and now we leave gaming cards behind
entirely. 96 to 192 GB. This is
workstation territory and it is defined
by one specific little box that rewrote
the math for the whole tier. Nvidia's
DGX Spark, a 1.2 kg box that sits under
your monitor with 128 GB of unified
memory for around $4,000. It holds
models a $4,000 graphics card cannot
even load. And the model built for
exactly this box landed on July 21st,
Laguna S2.1 from a San Francisco startup
called Poolside. An open weight coding
model and a genuinely surprising one. It
is 118 billion parameters, but only
eight are active at any one time. That
is a mixture of experts. Most of the
model sits dormant on each token and
that sparsity is exactly why it drops
onto a single spark and still runs fast.
Here is the surprise.
On terminal bench, a long horizon coding
test where an agent drives a real
terminal, Laguna scores 70% and beats
DeepSeek's flagship at 1.6 trillion
parameters. It is beating a model
roughly 14 times its size. Poolside is
calling it the West's most capable open
weight model and on its size class, the
claim mostly holds up.
40% on Deep Sue, a harder test where
trillion parameter open models routinely
score under 10. And it is not just a
number on a chart. In one unbroken
50-minute run, no human help, Laguna
built a working browser engine from an
empty folder. Then proved it works by
rendering pages against real Chromium
and comparing pixel for pixel. It is not
flawless and Poolside says so out loud.
It can overthink a simple task for ages
and it sometimes fumbles an unfamiliar
tool format. But an open model that
argues with itself until the test
actually pass is a genuinely new kind of
thing to own. It ships with up to a
million tokens of context and an open
license and it went from the first day
of training to launch in under 9 weeks.
That release cadence is its own kind of
warning shot and getting it is easy. The
weights are on hugging face from day one
and vllm sglang and a llama all run it
locally out of the box.
Nvidia even tuned it to serve on a
single spark. This is built to be used,
not admired. Frontier grade agentic
coding, the kind that was locked inside
a cloud API 6 months ago, now running on
a box that fits in your backpack. Top
rung 192
to 384 GB. Two of those sparks lashed
together or a proper server.
Very few people are up here, but if you
are, the reward is the best open model
on earth that is not from America or
China.
It is called Motif 3 and it comes from a
Korean startup, Motif Technologies. 314
billion parameters, a mixture of
experts, and this is the part one
respect, built from scratch, not a
fine-tune of somebody else's model.
Under the hood, it is a sparse design.
384 expert networks and only a handful
fire on any given token. So, about 13
billion parameters are doing the work at
a time. Big brain, cheap to run, and
here is where it sits.
On artificial analysis, the industry's
main intelligence ranking, Motif 3 is
the third best open weight model in the
entire world.
Only Chimney K 3 and GLM 5.2 are ahead
of it. If artificial analysis is new to
you, it is the closest thing this field
has to a neutral scoreboard.
One index that folds a batch of hard
reasoning and a genetic test into a
single number.
Third place on it as a model you can
host yourself is a very big deal. And
sit with the company it is keeping. The
two models above it are Chinese giants.
Chimney K 3 alone is 2.8 trillion
parameters. MoE is a fraction of that
size from a firm most people have never
heard of and it is right on their heels.
314 billion is a lot, but sparse and
quantized to 8-bit, it lands around 300
GB, and less if you push the
quantization squarely inside a two spark
or a single server budget. Why does a
top three open model matter to you
specifically? Because open weight means
you can download it, run it behind your
own walls, and nobody can rate limit
you, price hike you, or take it away in
a product update. That is the whole
ladder, five brackets, five models, and
every one of them ran on hardware you
can sit on a desk. So, let's line them
up one more time. 4 to 8 gigs, Nambeage.
8 to 24, Bonsai. 24 to 96, Qwen with a
thinking cap. 96 to 192,
Laguna on a spark. And above that, MoE.
Now, the honest catch, because I'm not
going to oversell it, none of these are
GPT-5.6 or Claude Fable.
The closed frontier still sits around 90
on these coding tests, and local still
trails it. This is the best you can own,
not the best that exists. So, how do you
choose? Simplest rule I can give you,
find the biggest model that fits your
memory with a little room left over for
context, and run that one.
When it fits, bigger still wins. It is
almost that boring, but the real
headline is not any single model on this
list. It is that the one that fits your
box today is dramatically better than
the one that fit it six months ago. The
floor is rising, and it is rising fast.
And if you have never done this, do not
overthink it.
A llama is one install and one command,
a llama run, then the model name.
LM Studio is the same idea with a
friendly window and a download button.
You are about 10 minutes from a private
model, not a weekend, because every
model here is a free download on Hugging
Face. Pull the one for your bracket,
load it up tonight, and go find out what
your own hardware can actually do.
I really think it is going to surprise
you. If this saved you a week of trial
and error, subscribe. I break down the
local AI stack here every week. I will
see you on the next.